they're negotiating tactics haven't been
particularly good the language has been
appalling there's no doubt about that
and I think that ever done anything like
this before so it's put the Europeans
backs up but fundamentally I think the
differences are tiny in terms of the
overall amount of money which the
Europeans are expecting the Greeks to
raise or cuts in terms of the budget
there should be in theory in agreement
and his peanuts in relation to
everything else is going on there are
those who say well under these
conditions of austerity Greece simply
cannot go on like this because of the
pressures already there in society what
would you say to them oh I think I agree
with that I think also he would have
that tsipras would have great difficulty
getting anything additional passed
through his own Parliament let alone
whatever may be happening with the
European Parliament's I need to pass the
agreements as well but the Greek
parliament is just not going to buy
because he has very very tough a sort of
left better radical left of his party to
deal with they're not going to buy a lot
more austerity so at the end of the day
what is the essence of any agreement
that needs to be made is looking at a
debt situation and if the debt situation
can be resolved somehow so there are
some sort of forgiveness which of course
that's the point what the three he's
negotiating would say they won't do well
of course but in addition of course to
forgiveness you can have extending
maturities which already happened before
you can have lowering of interest rates
again and the interesting thing to
remember is that back in two thousand
twelve the things was when the second
bailout was negotiated the Greeks were
told at the time different government of
course that if a primary surplus was
achieved with the Greeks achieved then
they would look again at renegotiating
the debt oh look look at whether the
debt was sustainable because it is the
Greeks would have met which they have
done so all the physical expectations so
you feel basically eurozone is being
unreasonable and I think the
considerable extent i do but i think the
greeks haven't been particularly helpful
either i always thought that we'd reach
a deal because there will be compromised
on both sides that see the lights and
then no other people don't want to leave
the euro and the know the people want to
be part of the EU maybe for political
reasons because the grease want to be
attached to this continent where as the
cutoff is you know geographic gain away
and the all these geopolitical things
all around it all the problems of the
Middle East and Africa and so on are
quite unnerving so they want to be part
of something that they can
belong to so they know that they have to
reach a deal which keeps the Greek
people happy and I think if for some
reason it looks like grexit is really
seriously as a prospect then I think
they will lose an awful lot of support